on capitol hill democrats are still
working on two massive spending packages
that house leaders hope to approve this
week meanwhile in the senate last night
republicans blocked a short-term budget
bill that would also raise the national
debt limit that increases the odds that
the government will run out of money and
will have to shut down on friday chris
van cleave is on capitol hill for us
chris good morning
good morning tony let's be clear the
clock is ticking and there's not a lot
of time left for democrats to come
together to advance the president's
domestic agenda speaker pelosi senator
schumer and the president spoke
yesterday the white house is pledging to
stay in close contact with the hill as
they chart the path forward
this morning the government is less than
72 hours from running out of money
forcing a partial shutdown and leaving
about 800 thousand government workers
without a paycheck the motion is not
agreed to last night all 50 senate
republicans blocked a temporary funding
extension that would have also suspended
the debt ceiling avoiding a potentially
catastrophic default on the country's
debt our country is staring down the
barrel of two totally republican
manufactured disasters
a government shutdown and a first ever
default we're not willing to help
democrats raise the debt ceiling
while they write a reckless taxing and
spending spree
of historic proportions already backed
into a legislative corner democrats are
racing the clock and fighting discord in
their ranks to rescue president biden's
domestic agenda our members are so
idealistic
strategic
and
interested in getting results house
speaker nancy pelosi now aims to pass
the president's one trillion dollar
infrastructure bill on its own thursday
reversing a month's long vow to only
pass it along with his larger 3.5
trillion dollar budget bill progressive
democrats have threatened to sink the
infrastructure package if the larger
spending legislation isn't ready to go i
don't believe it'll come for a vote
unless we get the reconciliation bill
done and i think that will be hard
because
you know we've got to get everything
agreed on the key senators including
west virginia's joe manchin remain
resistant to the price tag
really good on threats president biden
continues to work the phones remaining
publicly optimistic i think things are
going to go well i think we're going to
get it done
senate majority leader chuck schumer
says there is a plan b to keep the
government open and funded he didn't say
what it is but one possible solution
would be to try to pass this continuing
resolution again without the debt
ceiling attached to it tony
a lot of ifs all right chris thank you
very much